first of all nice to see you guys again
so soon seeing you guys more than I see
my friends was just amazing
well we are friends we go way back mean
you yeah won't tell that story right oh
I watched the movie again last night and
I enjoyed it even more and the thing
that I took away from it which I maybe I
just was stupid the first time was how
amazing Steven did with balancing the
humor and heart like he peppered in
these great brilliant jokes all
throughout the movie can you sort of
talk about that that balancing of the
humor and heart yes I mean I agree when
I first saw it I was like that it's got
not only the story and the family that
you fall in love with but it's got their
wicked dirty sense of humor throughout
the film and it's so naughty
it's so naughty but you pick up their
love for each other immediately you know
II know that it's just there's no lies
in that family it's just all out there
all the dirty laundry's out there and
that's how they communicate and it
really works
I agree yeah I mean that's what makes it
totally real though and authentic is
that that is what the family is like and
if it had been done any other way I
think that would have been lying in a
sense they do feel completely emotional
when one minute and then say something
horrendous the wrecks that is the family
and that's what's so endearing and
beautiful about them so I think Steven
did a really good job there absolutely
now that you've been a week or two
removed from Sundance yeah looking back
on it what was this whole experience
like because everyone I spoke to loved
the movie and I'm just curious what this
whole thing was like the release of it
no just being at Sundance you know very
fun I think I was I think I was part of
struggle the way well yeah all the way
no I wasn't
all the way through sometimes is always
such a pleasure to go and you always
feel very blessed to be there and I
think especially with a film like this
which is just so easy to talk about it
was a joy to be there and to talk about
it with fellow castmates yeah yeah I've
never I'd never been to on snow you suit
Sundance they in that big coat my snow
boots
yeah no I had been and going anywhere
with something that you don't fully love
is tough but going somewhere with
something that you truly love is this it
is easy fun right well it was just
really I have that is absolutely true
although it's pretty cold today yeah
this is kind of beating it I feel it's
not messing around I have a few words
called fun questions completely
hopefully you'll think they're fun
everyone know what's what TV show would
you guys love to guest star on Oh
Breaking Bad it's gone now so I've
missed the boat glow sure possibility on
well do you have a favorite sci-fi or
fantasy film avatar et ah but I do love
avatar I'd love to do like Nick dust do
your yeah I what's funny is I just spoke
to Jon Landau and they just wrapped
principal on on the stage of avatar for
cuz they're making for sequels what two
two three four and five know this but I
don't I think everyone saw see the thing
is two three four five I'd love to be in
the fifth one I know everyone's offering
right now but by the time the faithful
comes out like everybody will be down
because they've seen four of them do you
don't mean I don't know but they're
doing that with Star Wars inherently
it's like everything is but I've already
but I'm already bit done with Star Wars
promised I do love them but I feel like
they should Peter them out a little bit
longer like it should be a lot longer in
between though gyro yeah you know you
are a hundred percent right they need to
be special occasion yeah yes not every
snow every exactly that's what I'm
talking about completely agree let's
jump into favorite superhero movie do
you have one Deadpool I wanna be that I
think it is Deadpool maybe yeah although
I just saw into the Spidey purse which I
loved
yeah so much into if you haven't seen
spider-man into the spider version it's
a phenomenal it's it's one of my
favorite movie like it went straight
there keep on going I'm just gonna be
thinking about that question
what film scared you as a kid jewels
mine was I remember accidentally
watching the ring well accident like oh
my god that's terrible it's not cool no
and then people would leave the taps on
purpose to like really screw with me or
what they used to do was at school they
would put the face on the on the home
screen and then they'd sleep the
computer so when you'd go and move the
mouse the face would come up and I
remember weeing myself it's pure wheat
herself everyone I mean to the face of
the ring come on it's terrifying
I completely agree yeah do you remember
your first movie or TV show crush Leo
just in everything he does oh and um and
Danny from Greece yes I would I would
rewind the last 10 minutes over more so
than the amount of time it took to watch
the film I would probably be watching
that film for probably about four or
five hours and I've been winding the
last 10 minutes every time I plan don't
sing with him I think Lost Boys probably
Kiefer and Jane Pat yep since I'm
basically almost out of time what TV
show have you watch all the way through
more than one
Breaking Bad I've watched that about
three times
yeah that's genius I'm desperate
housewives' it house was porch kick I
was really into that when I was about
knowing that's for how that I've never
seen it what never know my goodness you
need to I got it you know long go around
oh my god
[Music]
individual question for each of you what
was it like doing Little Women which I
cannot wait to see and I I'm such a I'm
a huge fan of Game of Thrones and I
don't want to know anything about the
final season is been canceled
right exactly you go Cup right yeah but
I am curious for you when did you
realize because it's a worldwide
phenomenon when did you first realize
that this thing is beyond what you ever
thought it might be do you know what I
mean yeah no in the beginning I think
all of us were slightly skeptical in the
beginning and probably not until the
second season after it been out and it
was sort of gathering momentum then we
were getting a lot of feedback from
everybody and I think we're all like so
it just it's built as it's gone along
woman this last year was interesting for
all of us going never gonna happen again
it's bonkers how many years is it eight
seasons but like nine on it so it was
probably the third year in that you
realized it was kidding yeah it was like
serious maybe would go for another year
really mostly I'm so excited to watch it
too it was such an amazing experience
just I've never quite worked with
dialogue like that before and they talk
about it so often because it's it's just
really exciting to be greater as like an
engineer of amazing dialogue and of
heroine talk and it was just so exciting
to work in that way and with such
incredible women it was it was a pinch
me moment probably every day
that just like gazing at Merrill
[Music]